[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und guten
Abend den Sport hat Norbert Lehmann für
Sie einen schönen guten Abend und die
Blicke gehen heute besonders nach
Amerika
richtungswahlen in den USA die
regierende Demokraten müssen um ihre
Mehrheit im Parlament bangen
Club der klimaforreiter Bundeskanzler
Scholz wirkt in Sharm el Sheik für einen
klimafreundlichen Umbau der globalen
Industrie
nach interviewen ZDF bezeichnet der
wm-botschafter von Katha Homosexualität
als Geisteskrankheit
[Musik]
es entspannende Stunden in den USA die
Zwischenwahlen haben begonnen das heißt
Teile des Kongresses werden neu gewählt
und Präsident beiden und seine
Demokraten könnten dabei ihre Mehrheiten
sowohl im Senat als auch im
Repräsentantenhaus an die Republikaner
verlieren dadurch würde das Regieren für
beiden deutlich schwerer
schauen wir einmal auf die beiden
Parlamentskammern um die es geht
Repräsentantenhaus werden alle 435 Sitze
neu vergeben im Senat gut ein Drittel
der 100-sitze zurzeit haben die
Demokraten die Mehrheit in beiden
Kammern wenn auch im Senat nur äußerst
knapp die mit terms finden in allen
Bundesstaaten statt eine wichtige
Richtungswahl wenn er mir Daniel aus
Washington
lange Schlangen um die Wahllokale im
ganzen Land die amerikanische
Gesellschaft ist polarisiert und
mobilisiert knapp 45 Millionen Stimmen
wurden in den USA sogar schon vor dem
heutigen Wahltag abgegeben ein neuer
Rekord bei Zwischenwahlen
ich glaube wir haben Demokratie zu lange
als selbstverständlich empfunden in
Amerika und wir sehen Kräfte die nicht
daran interessiert sind festzuhalten an
unseren demokratischen Normen auf die
wir aber doch angewiesen sind
ich bin sehr unzufrieden mit der
aktuellen Regierung deshalb habe ich für
einen Wandel in Amerika gestimmt
bis zuletzt kämpfte Joe Biden um jede
Stimme seinen letzten Stopp beim
Wahlkampf Endspurt machte er in bioi
Maryland in seiner Rede warnte der
Präsident vor noch mehr Spaltung und
Aggressivität die das Land zunehmend
unter Druck setzten
wir stehen am Scheideweg es ist ein
Moment den wir nur alle drei vier
Generationen erleben im Innern wissen
wir dass unsere Demokratie auf dem Spiel
steht und dass das jetzt der Zeitpunkt
ist sie zu verteidigen sie zu beschützen
uns für Sie zu entscheiden
vor wenigen Stunden gab auch Donald
Trump seine Stimme in Palm Beach Florida
ab am Vorabend heizte er seinen
Anhängern in Dayton Ohio ein
i love you die Zerstörung unseres Landes
stoppen und in amerikanischen Traum
retten wolls dann müsst ihr in einer
riesigen roten Welle abstimmen
laut letzten Umfragen könnte es
tatsächlich eine rote republikanische
Welle geben die Demokraten könnten beide
kongresskammern verlieren wo noch nie
stand bei Zwischenwahlen so viel auf dem
Spiel nicht nur für die regierenden
Demokraten sondern auch für die
Demokratie in Amerika
und es sieht also nach einer hohen
Wahlbeteiligung aus MRT wir sind in
Washington wer könnte davon profitieren
die Demokraten oder die Republikaner
also es lässt sich verlässlich
eigentlich kaum sagen das hat damit zu
tun dass wir wissen die Demokraten haben
in den vergangenen Monaten 10.000 von
neu Wählern registrieren können und die
sind für Meinungsumfragen schlicht und
ergreifende unbeschriebene Blätter man
weiß nicht wie ihr Wahlverhalten ist es
kommt dazu dass viele Amerikaner sich
weigern wegen der Polarisierung im Land
auch offen zu sagen wen sie wählen
wollen mit anderen Worten die Umfragen
könnten möglicherweise falsch sein die
jetzt voraussagen dass es eben deutliche
Siege für die Republikaner gibt das ist
auch für Donald Trump wichtig der am 15
November also nächsten Dienstag eine
Neuigkeit verkünden will so hat er
gesagt also wahrscheinlich ob er
antreten will zur Präsidentschaftswahl
und ich glaube das abhängig davon ob es
einen deutlichen Sieg der Republikaner
gibt sowohl hier im Kongress als auch
eben in den einzelnen Bundesstaaten für
die Ämter dort man sieht es ist eine
sehr wichtige und sehr spannende Wahl
dankeschön
und die aktuellen Geschehnisse rund um
die mithörens haben Sie bei uns online
immer im Blick ein Live-Blog informiert
Sie über die neuesten Zwischenstände
rund um die Uhr in unserer heute App
bei der Weltklimakonferenz ging es heute
unter anderem um mehr Hilfen für die
ärmeren und besonders von der Klimakrise
betroffenen Länder es ist in der
Verantwortung der G20 Länder die für 80%
der weltweiten Emissionen verantwortlich
sind dass wir überleben können so etwa
der Ministerpräsident der Cook in seinem
Pazifik Brown über das Ringen um
ehrgeizigere Klimaschutzziele in Sharm
el Sheikh berichtet Lisa Miebach
Proteste sind hier in Sharm el-Sheikh
während des Besuchs der Regierungschefs
eigentlich verboten während die
Deutschen Fridays for future Aktivisten
hier trotzdem protestieren wird Kanzler
Scholz auf der Konferenz weiter auch bei
Staaten wie China und Indien für seinen
Klima Club zur Minderung von
Treibhausgasemissionen doch den Club
sehen viele hier skeptisch der klimaklub
ist das persönliche Prestige Projektchen
von Kanzler Scholz aber so richtig will
das eigentlich keiner und es hilft auch
nicht den Klimaschutz international
voranzubringen das letzte was es jetzt
braucht ist noch ein weiteren
Gesprächskreis wo man sich über das
Klima unterhält es gibt hier die Welt
Klimakonferenz Kooperation will
Deutschland auch in einer neuen
Partnerschaft mit Kenia zeigen Kenia ist
schon Vorreiter mit 90% erneuerbaren
Energien mit Deutschlands Unterstützung
will es auf 100% kommen
doch ein Thema überlagert heute alle
klimazusagen der Hungerstreik eines
Aktivisten der für seine Proteste in
Ägypten im Gefängnis gefoltert wird
Allah Abdel fata Ulla Scholz hat darüber
sogar mit dem ägyptischen Präsidenten
gesprochen es ist sehr bedrückend zu
sehen dass
hier ein Menschenleben gefährdet ist und
der Hungerstreik ist jetzt in ein
Stadium getreten wo wir alle befürchten
müssen dass das wirklich zu ganz
furchtbaren Konsequenzen führt deshalb
habe ich und wie ich weiß auch noch
viele andere Staats- und Regierungschefs
das konkret angesprochen und gesagt da
muss jetzt etwas entschieden werden da
muss eine Freilassung möglich werden es
ist ein Zeichen dass Deutschland die
Schwester des bekannten Aktivisten sogar
heute am deutschen Pavillon empfängt ein
möglicher Wendepunkt das auf
Klimakonferenzen Klimaschutz und
Menschenrechte zusammen im Fokus stehen
überraschend hat Scholz jetzt also die
Freilassung des inhaftierten
demokratieaktivisten Elfer Tag gefordert
golinär atai wie wird das aufgenommen
nun von Seiten Ägyptens habe ich den
Eindruck wird das was der Bundeskanzler
hier gesagt hat notgedrungen toleriert
von Seiten der ägyptischen
Menschenrechtler wird natürlich begrüßt
dass es endlich internationale
Aufmerksamkeit gibt für ihre Lage das
ist ja lange Zeit nicht der Fall gewesen
nicht nur dass der Bundeskanzler
ungewohnt deutlich gewesen ist der hat
sich heute im Laufe des Tages auch noch
mit einem weiteren Bürgerrechtler hier
getroffen also Deutschland hat hier ganz
bewusst das Thema Zivilgesellschaft auf
die Agenda gesetzt die Agenda der
Klimakonferenz auch wenn es von Seiten
Ägyptens dadurch deutliche Kritik
erfahren hat alle ab den Partei ist ja
so etwas wie die Ikone der arabischen
Revolution 2011 gewesen er ist beileibe
nicht der einzige Fall es gibt
zehntausende politische Gefangene hier
in den Gefängnissen darunter auch
Journalisten im Bereich Wirtschaft setzt
Deutschland unverändert seine
Zusammenarbeit mit Ägypten fort da hat
die Deutsche Bahn heute hier einen
milliardenvertrag erg und zwar geht es
um das betreiben und es entstand Halten
des ersten Hochgeschwindigkeitsnetzes
hier in Ägypten und da wurde heute ein
Vertrag in einem einstelligen
Milliardenbereich unterzeichnet aus
Ägypten goldene erteilt dankeschön
am 20 November beginnt die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar in
einem ZDF-Interview hat sich ein
wm-botschafter cutters jetzt
schulenfeindlich geäußert die deutsche
Innenministerin Phaser nannte die
Aussagen furchtbar der Lesben und
schwulenverband fordert vom Auswärtigen
Amt eine Reisewarnung und rief zu einem
Boykott der WM auf mehr dazu von Stefan
Behr
es zeichnet sich ab dass Homosexuelle
Fans die Fußball-WM in Katar nicht ohne
erhebliche Bedenken besuchen können das
ergibt sich aus den Aussagen des
offiziellen
wm-botschaftersmann den ZDF Moderator
Jochen Breyer in Katar getroffen hat
dort ist schwul sein Haram das heißt
verboten ich bin kein strenger Muslim
aber warum ist es heran es ist ein
geistiger Schaden
der Pressesprecher des
Organisationskomitees brach das Gespräch
nach dieser Aussage ab
Innenministerin Nancy fazer war in der
letzten Woche mit Sicherheitsgarantien
auch für Homosexuelle WM-Besucher aus
Deutschland aus Katha zurückgekehrt die
hat mir der Premierminister und
Innenminister gegeben ich habe jetzt
keine neuen
Anzeichen von ihm selbst dass sich daran
etwas geändert haben sollte aber
natürlich sind solche Äußerungen
furchtbar und das ist ja auch der Grund
warum wir daran arbeiten dass ich Dinge
in Katar hoffentlich perspektivisch auch
verbessern die
Menschenrechtsorganisation Human Rights
Watch warnt Homosexuelle vor einer Reise
ins Land der WM Endrunde wir haben immer
wieder dokumentiert dass schwule Männer
Transgender Frauen verfolgt werden
geschlagen werden das sind die Haare
abgeschoren werden dass sie zu
Geständnissen gezwungen werden also
diese Lage ist für die ganze queer
Community wirklich katastrophal der
Blick hinter die Kulissen des
Gastgeberlandes zeigt den Widerspruch
zwischen aktuellen Ansichten von WM
Repräsentanten und offiziellen
Verlautbarungen aus der
bewerbungsperiode die fußball-w findet
in einem Land statt in dem bei Menschen
und Persönlichkeitsrechten andere
Maßstäbe gelten als zum Beispiel in
Deutschland
Jochen Breyer hatte das Interview mit
dem wm-botschafter Kattas geführt Jochen
nach diesen schwulenfeindlichen Aussagen
wie schätzen Sie das ein können schwule
lesbische queere Menschen sicher zur WM
reisen
das ist sehr schwer vorhersehbar also
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass schwule
und lesbische Fans dort in Gefahr sind
oder Gefahr laufen festgenommen zu
werden denn die katarische Führung weiß
ja genau was das zur Folge hätte einen
weltweiten Aufschrei negative PR und
genau das will Katha ja nicht sie wollen
ja aus dieser WM eine Werbeschau machen
sich inszenieren aus meiner Sicht geht
es aber bei diesem Thema um mehr als nur
um Sicherheit queere Fans sind
willkommen alle sind willkommen sagt der
Emir mantraartig und die Aussagen von
Halle Salman die wir gerade gehört haben
sagen eben das Gegenteil dass queere
Fans schwule Fans lesbische Fans eben
nicht willkommen sind in Katar und damit
sind wir mal wieder beim
Weltfußballverband FIFA der schreibt
sich Werte wie Toleranz und Vielfalt
immer in ganz dicken lässern auf die
Fahnen vergibt die WM dann in ein Land
dass diese Werte eben nicht schätzt im
Gegenteil und duckt sich jetzt in all
diesen Debatten weg und das finde ich
persönlich mindestens genauso
problematisch wie die Aussagen des
wm-botschafter
danke für diese Einschätzung Jochen
Breyer
und die schalte haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet Geheimsache Katha
die Doku von Julia Friedrichs und Jochen
Breyer können Sie heute um 20 Uhr und
jederzeit in der ZDF Mediathek sehen
nach Angaben aus Kiew führte ukrainische
Präsident selenske kommende Woche am
G20-Gipfel in Indonesien teilnehmen
vermutlich per Videoschalte unterdessen
gehen die Kämpfe im Land weiter auch
rund um das Atomkraftwerk saporicia das
in der Hand russischer Truppen ist
unsere Porter daran hassanzade hat sich
auf der anderen Seite des Flusses
umgeschaut
wir fahren nach nicopol es liegt genau
gegenüber dem größten Atomkraftwerk
Europas es ist von der russischen Armee
besetzt und produziert nur noch Strom
für die eigene Kühlung
die russische Armee Besch schießt uns
mit Artillerie vom Gelände des AKWs sie
bewahren dort ihre Munition und
Ausrüstung auf das AKW ist de facto zu
einem Militärstützpunkt geworden wir
wissen das und unsere Position bleibt
dieselbe unsere Militär ist es verboten
das Gelände des AKWs oder Bereiche in
der Nähe unter Beschuss zu nehmen dieses
Verbot ist nicht diskutabel
so sind der ukrainischen Armee hier die
Hände gebunden und die Menschen in
nicopol täglichen Beschuss ausgesetzt
es ist schwer in meiner Geburtsstadt zu
leben jeder einzelne Nacht kommen Bomben
um zwei um drei um vier und um 5 Uhr
unsere Morgenstunden sind ziemlich laut
Schutz finden Sie in öffentlichen
Bunkern bis zu 80 Menschen schlafen hier
Nacht für Nacht tagsüber wird aufgebaut
was zuvor zerstört wurde doch nahezu
kein Straßenzug ohne Kriegsschäden es
ist eine bedrückende Atmosphäre hier in
nicopol die Menschen leben hier in
Reichweite der russischen Artillerie und
man spürt ihre Angst jederzeit kann es
Einschläge geben und doch gehen Sie
Ihren normalen Tätigkeiten nach
eine Demilitarisierung des
Atomkraftwerks würde den Menschen hier
viele Sorgen nehmen nicht nur Ihnen
nach Deutschland wie sicher fühlen sich
hier die Menschen Innenministerin Phaser
und der Chef des Bundeskriminalamtes
Münch haben heute dazu eine Studie
vorgestellt es ist die größte Befragung
die es in Deutschland je zu Erfahrungen
mit Kriminalität gab der Ergebnisse von
Klaus Brodbeck der Weg durch die
Dunkelheit die Einsamkeit im nächtlichen
Nahverkehr unheimlich Furcht als
ständige Begleiterin unheimlich vertraut
die Studie zeigt so geht es vielen die
meisten Menschen fühlen sich in der
eigenen Wohnung und im eigenen
Wohnumfeld sicher allerdings und das
macht mir Sorge Frauen fühlen sich
nachts in der Öffentlichkeit deutlich
unsicherer bestimmte Orte meiden in der
Dunkelheit 44 Prozent den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr 37% aller Befragten bei
Frauen liegen diese Werte deutlich höher
mehr als jede zweite hat Angst
Message an an die Berliner
Stadtverwaltung mehr Straßenlaternen vor
allem jetzt wo es um 17 Uhr dunkel wird
wenn man da joggen gehen will abends die
Hälfte der Parks ist nicht beleuchtet
und da fühle ich mich auf jeden Fall
unsicher ich war viele im Ausland ob
viele im Ausland gelebt
körperlich physisch seelisch
gesundheitlich fühle ich mich sehr
sicher Pfefferspray das hat man immer
dabei vor allem wenn man nachts dann
feiern geht schon zur Sicherheit ja am
häufigsten berichteten die Befragten
über Straftaten im Internet Angst vor
Betrug dort haben 42 Prozent keine
Geldgeschäfte übers Internet machen 27
Prozent der Zentrale Befund ist
Kriminalität im Internet hat erhebliche
Ausmaße und es besorgt die Befragten
auch stark langfristig soll die Studie
einen breiteren Blick auf die
Entwicklung von Kriminalität ermöglichen
gleichwohl gilt auch für die Befragten
Deutschland als eines der sichersten
Länder der Welt
das Hightech-Unternehmen elmos
entwickelt produziert und verkauft
Halbleiter meistens für die
Autoindustrie einen Teil der Firma die
Chipherstellung wollten die Dortmunder
nun für 85 Millionen Euro an einen
chinesischen Staatskonzern verkaufen
aber das wird wohl nichts
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck will die
Übernahme verhindern und morgen einen
Verbotsantrag ins Kabinett einbringen
gut vier Wochen nach der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen ist Stefan weil als
Ministerpräsident bestätigt worden der
SPD-Politiker startet damit in seine
dritte Amtszeit der neue rot-grüne
Landesregierung will noch in diesem
Monat ein eigenes Entlastungspaket auf
den Weg bringen um die hohen
Energiekosten abzufedern außerdem wollen
SPD und Grüne den Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien vorantreiben mehr bezahlbaren
Wohnraum sowie höhere Einstiegsgehälter
für viele Lehrkräfte
wir kommen jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga
Norbert Stress für die Vereine weil es
ist ja englische Woche heute und morgen
9 Spiele und natürlich am Wochenende
auch am Abend empfängt der neue
Tabellenführer Bayern München Werder
Bremen der Aufsteiger überraschend sieht
danach 13 Spieltagen der muss ohne den
verletzten Torjäger Niklas Füllkrug
antreten
sein
Tormann gegen die
[Applaus]
beiden Niklas Füllkrug fällt mit einer
Rückenverletzung aus aber ist jetzt
trotz alledem nichts nichts gravierendes
wird gegen Leipzig höchstwahrscheinlich
dann auch wieder zur Verfügung stehen
auch Mitchell weiser ist in Bremen nicht
mehr wegzudenken in herausragender Form
und heute Schlüsselspieler zum 111 mal
treffen die Bayern auf Bremen dass es
Bundesliga-Rekord und die Münchner
wollen ihre neu erklommenen Tabellen
Thron verteidigen wir wollen gerne auf
Platz 1 sein das sind wir jetzt jetzt
müssen wir die sechs Punkte holen dann
bleiben es auch über die Pause oder über
die WM die Münchner Offensive läuft
mittlerweile rund Erik Choupo-Moting
schoss in sieben Pflichtspielen neun
Tore dazu Manet muss Jala gnabry nur
Thomas Müller fällt mit Muskelproblemen
aus aber Manuel Neuer ist wieder fit das
Tor somit gut bewacht
Niederlage der deutschen Handballfrauen
bei der EM gegen Gastgeber Montenegro
gab es gestern Abend ein 25 zu 29 das
DHB-Team tritt morgen im letzten
Gruppenspiel gegen Spanien an ja und hat
das Erreichen der Hauptrunde noch selbst
in der Hand
kräftetanken ein bisschen Regeneration
und den Fokus neu ausrichten denn das
Vorrunden Aus droht am Tag nach der
Niederlage ist klar es wird ein
Entscheidungsspiel schon in der Vorrunde
morgen gegen Spanien
ja absolut da geht es um alles alles
oder nichts Weiterkommen rausfliegen das
ist ein Spiel wo wir natürlich unter
Druck stehen aber ich glaube dass wir
gute Chancen haben Spanien zu besiegen
den vorzeitigen Finaleinzug haben die
deutschen Frauen verpasst im zweiten
Spiel gegen Montenegro lagen sie hier in
Weiß zwischenzeitlich zwar noch gleich
auf das 17 zu 17 durch Emily Birk doch
trotz großem Kampf verloren sie das
Spiel 25 zu 29 seit WM Bronze 2007
warten die deutschen Handballerinnen auf
eine Medaille bei einem großen Turnier
das war es von Sport Dankeschön Norbert
und wir haben jetzt noch eine
archäologische Sensation aus dem Schlamm
für Sie Ort des kleinen Wunders eine
toskanische Thermalanlage die vor
Ewigkeiten versiegelt wurde jetzt haben
forschende einfach mal unter den Stein
nachgesehen und Überraschung 24
Bronzestatuen gefunden der
thermal-schlamm nahezu perfekt
konserviert hat tausende Münzen auch aus
Gold fanden sich quasi nebenbei ein
Schatz groß genug für ein ganzes Museum
über truskische Kultur das jetzt
entstehen soll
morgen überquert uns das Regenband von
tief philomena wie viel Regen es bringt
und wie es danach weitergeht erfahren
Sie gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal können Sie um 21.45 sehen mit
Anne Gellinek machen sie es gut
[Musik]
Abend 8 November und 20 Jahr gerundet 21
Grad das sind typische Temperaturen zum
Beispiel für die Kanarischen Inseln in
Müllheim oder Baden-Baden ist das doch
eher ungewöhnlich wird jetzt aber auch
sich ändern und das liegt an der
Kaltfront von tief philomena diese
Kaltfront bringt uns schon heute Nacht
und dann morgen über Tag Regen wenn die
Karl von abgezogen ist übernimmt hoch
Charlie mit Sonnenschein Nebel und
Hochnebel schon heute Nacht setzt also
im Westen Regen ein hier in Südostbayern
bleibt es trocken da bildet sich zum
Teil Nebel und da sinken die
Temperaturen auf +4 bis -1 Grad sonst
liegen die Nachttemperaturen bei 13 bis
6 Grad in etwas milderen Milieu und
morgen liegen die Temperaturen bei 11
bis 16 Grad das wird also nicht mehr so
warm wie noch heute und der Regen der
Nacht sieht ein bisschen weiter auswärts
so zwischen Rügen und Basel etwa meist
sind das nur so fünf bis zehn Liter pro
Quadratmeter die innerhalb von 24
Stunden runterkommen im Südwesten können
es auch mal 10 bis 20 im Schwarzwald 20
bis 30 Liter pro Quad werden hier in
Ostbayern da bleibt es den ganzen Tag
über trocken Schauer und Gewitter gibt
es dann an der Nordsee und danach wird
es von Tag zu Tag sonniger und ruhiger
wir sehen uns